okay here we are and which Republican
candidate has the best chance of winning
the general election of the declared
ones right now Donald Trump Scott Walker
would you say the ones are clear no I'm
Romney Walker's my second Romney Walker
see but last time you were you said if
we elect if we nominate Romney will
definitely lose and I was right but well
why will he win this
that was the choice and it was because
actually for well it was third time time
was the charm for Reagan right it was
because it's very hard to take out an
incumbent and the reason I supported
Christie back then and don't know was
because you know he's so flashy and and
idiosyncratic they we probably were
gonna lose but the only shot we had was
this wild idiosyncratic I I think I
wanna crush Hillary I would do anything
for an Trump if you ran Bernie Sanders
that would be much tougher Bernie
Sanders it would be much tougher than
you think would be a better candidate
than Hillary yeah Wow yeah because he
would class working class Hillary does
and she's like the elected Republican
she cares about the chamber
reactions panel I think Marco Rubio well
you think it's gonna be Marco roof
I think Marco Rubio's got the best
chance and if you saw the announcement
he gave which follows a couple weeks ago
followed Hillary Clinton's start
contrast you know he talked about
yesterday a candidate from yesterday I
gave his speech about yesterday
I think Rubio has the the charisma the
sort of freshness he's Hispanic he
speaks fluent Spanish
that's that nothing's Cuban but he
speaks fluent oh I understand that sure
as they do in Cuba Ted Cruz Cruz doesn't
speak Spanish or Catalan is also rapists
I really don't what is his qualification
to actually be present in the United
States other than that he feels a
demographic hole for you he's more
qualified than Barack Obama he was a
Speaker of the House of Florida doubts
in Florida he passed immigration reform
he's a bipartisan immigrant he tested
bipartisan immigration with hard for a
baby and he passed it in the Senate the
US that's not passing it he passed it in
the Senate that's nothing that's like
you know how a bill becomes a law yes
I'm
champion immigration reform when I take
on the Titanic I think I think that you
don't like Rubio no I mean all he's done
I mean first he violated his pledge
debrie on saying comprehensive
immigration reform and that's amnesty
I'm against it he gets people to vote
for what do you want to do with the 15
year or do you want to do those still
talking what do you want any spends what
do we do and we know it's not popular
which is why I'd prefer Bernie Sanders
to Hillary Clinton who's now on the side
of the senior partners because you are
out of the box the American people have
three times shut down an amnesty in the
last ten years and it's not because any
network or any politician other than you
know a few very small ones we're
opposing it it was the American people
rising up and saying we don't want
amnesty so if that's your big selling
point when that's - nope well
seriousness right so I'm with you I want
to I want to secure the border I think
we need assimilation but if we have 15
or 30 or however 30 million however many
illegals here what do you do with them
if you don't have the pathway to
ridiculous to talk about it until the
border is that's what you lop out no it
isn't well what would you what no it
isn't you secure I agree let's secure
the border and then whatever 1986 Reagan
passed an amnesty saying this is it well
amnesty look that border security it was
a lie that we honor well for 30 million
Ronald Reagan against live first offense
be against immigration reform is for the
status quo
that means we keep the status quo the
fact is we have two million people
working in the fields every day in
America they provide us our machines now
if I could if I could and they provide
us with food and we should pay them a
decent salary because this is America
number two we are not going to deport
our way out of this Mitt Romney we've
written up rip Mitt Romney got more
white votes than any other candidate for
the presidency of the United States and
he still got his ass whipped by Barack
Hussein Obama by five million bucks
because because and so my point to you
build is there's this new American
coalition it's young people it's gay
people it's Latinos it's Hispanic it's
people who believe in the environment
and so when I saw Jeb Bush actually
attempt to broaden the tent of the
Republican Party
he had a diverse group of people he
spoke in English and in Spanish fluently
he was raising Democratic constituency
why don't we start banging the deck okay
why don't we started ragging with
Democrats why don't you guys try to cut
off more of the evangelical because you
are losing with that one thing that Ann
Coulter has to say I think it is
absolutely bit insulting to say that
Hispanics are going to like lemmings
vote for the Republican Party because
your candidate has an O at the end of
because the policies of the Democratic
Party everything poll will show you most
Latinos agree with apologies of the
demographic the American voter their
interests their voting the policies they
agree with if you want the American
Dream first thing you have to take off
is that I don't like you son because as
long as I have you if I get that but
that's not gonna win you an election
because I'm one voter but there are
millions without vote there are millions
of voters out there and when Donald
Trump and I what amazing public in what
are you Samaras on what he said I'm what
he said no one in the Republican Party
inotrope it says so if Jeb Bush
challenges Donald Trump challenges him
and wins and gets through some
miraculously get through the Republican
primaries I think then Latinos will say
God think I championed our cause he took
on the man that called us
rapists and murderers and he took him on
and you know what they will reward him
be
he's open all right all right let me go
on to another subject
did you lose at no Hispanic votes all
right you know what pop licking gets 40%
of the Hispanic vote he's the president
no yes yeah no you need 71% of the
Hispanic vote removing Mitt Romney still
would've lost 4% more of the white vote
he would have won so what is it a
Republicans fixated on and I do not
think you are speaking for the theist
the Hispanics in there right because
there is Romney should have been whiter
if the Supreme Court rules against
Obamacare can we count on Congress to
ensure that millions aren't left without
insurance absolutely not they're not
good I mean that Congress is so
dysfunctional at this point but the
irony will be if the Supreme Court rules
against the Affordable Care Act you're
gonna have millions of red state
Americans who will suddenly have their
middle-class insurance ripped out of
their hands while blue states who went
ahead and formed exchanges will still
have their insurance it'll be a crisis
for those members of Congress in those
red states that are gonna be fighting
from their constituents that wait a
minute I'm losing my health care I
thought it was just gonna be them and
when they find out that it's gonna be us
not them I think it's gonna be a problem
for the Republican Party all right Thank
You panel thank you what is your
terrific
you